ils en ont assez d'attendre d'attendre
que les pouvoirs publics permettent en
martinique et de consommer sans
chlordécone
le collectif 0 chlordécone constitué il
ya quelques mois a donc lancé une
initiative fédérer des producteurs qui
peuvent garantir des produits propres
il existe des agriculteurs qui ont la
volonté de fournir des produits propres
et là je ne parle vraiment pas de la
partie réglementaire mais la partie de
la démarche c'est à dire des
agriculteurs qui ont fait la démarche
est personnelle de vérifier que leur
terrain est à décontaminer qui ont fait
en sorte de deux d'utiliser des
protocoles qui eux aussi sont propres le
sort de fournir in fine et des produits
qui sont adaptés à la consommation en
parallèle un groupe pilote sera
constitué des gens capables de payer les
140 euros du test sanguin du chlordécone
ils le feront en septembre prochain avec
un objectif précis les personnes qui
sont dans
l'opération cordes et toc sont déjà pas
mal sensibiliser et l'idée c'est
d'élargir un peu la dynamique à tous
ceux qui veulent nous rejoindre et pour
pouvoir faire un comparatif a
aujourd'hui je faisais pas du tout
attention je fais un test et je regarde
quelques de cour d'école j'ai dans mon
sang et dans deux ans on refait le test
pour savoir combien de clubs d'écoles on
a dans le sang pour voir le système de
détoxification second pilote devra donc
consommer exclusivement en circuit
repérer sans chlordécone
il ne boira que des eaux locales en
bouteille qui ont déjà été testés c'est
un début car dans le public les
questions ne manquent pas la question de
l'eau potable revient d'ailleurs
régulièrement parfois je me dis oui je
veux bien la partie officielle
est-ce que je peux me fier surtout que
aujourd'hui je produis par rapport à
tout ce qui s'est passé par rapport aux
reportages on voit bien que bon les
autorités aujourd'hui ne sont pas prêts
à donner le maximum d'informations à
boubers en guadeloupe est bien le fils
n'a pas été changé les gens bu de l'eau
chlore déconner tu as trois semaines
qu'on a entendu cela a failli c'est donc
comme on est dans un processus quand
même 2 0 chlordécone bon l'eau du
robinet des collectes seront organisées
pour permettre des contrôles de l'eau ou
des aliments
le collectif 0 chlordécone espère par la
suite obtenir des réductions sur le prix
du test sanguin
si le groupe est suffisamment important
enfin il appelle les pêcheurs et
éleveurs qui ont des produits sains à
les rejoindre